so on election night the mainstream
media was having a duck fit that's what
we call it in Tennessee when people's
faces are turning inside out because
things aren't going the way they want
and they obviously were rooting for
Hillary and had been pretty obviously
doing so I mean we had a couple of
characters running we can all agree to
that without a doubt and one of the
characters won well because their
candidate didn't win these main
streamers on ABC and CBS and NBC and
MSNBC the mainstream media people are
all you know going oh now look the
economy's gonna crash look see what you
you know see what you uneducated white
people they voted for Trump did see what
you did you crash the economy and that's
what they were doing and they were
talking about the Dow futures are all
500 dollars are out $600 or look the
stock markets got a crash because you
people elected Trump you remember that
election night if you were not watching
election coverage you saw that because
they had to have something to you know
they had to some some way to prove that
the people that voted for Trump were
wrong um I was distressing you people
are just horrible journalists just
horrid I mean you didn't even feign act
like you were objective I'm not
supporting Trump I mean it was just
horrible TV it's just horrible well of
course you know the story the stock
market opened and the stock market
closed up that day and just moments ago
the stock market closed above $19,000
the first time in the hundred and 20
year history of the stock market now
does that mean the stock market loves
Trump no it means that some things in
the stock market loves some of the ideas
that he thinks he's going to pull off
and so stuff like energy stocks coal oil
shooting through-the-roof anything
having to do with infrastructure because
he's talking about spending a trillion
dollars where he's gonna get that who
knows but stock market reacted to it and
it is driven stock prices up is it false
no it's not false
we don't know what president-elect Trump
is going to do or not going to do or
gonna be able to pull off or not gonna
be able pull off god only knows
but obviously the economy did not crash
due to the little and a president
elected that the mainstream media didn't
like so just a note for those of you
think it took all your money out of the
stock market because you're worried
about Hillary or you're worried about
Trump I told you not to and the Dow
closes in record territory over 19,000 a
day see ride the waves people ride the
waves surfing is fun this is the Dave
Ramsey show hey guys thanks for watching
if you enjoyed this video click the
subscribe button to get the latest
content and check out these other great
clips from the show